those demonstrations in kenosha have
been mostly peaceful in recent days and
jacob blake's family is among those
calling
for non-violence our mola lenghi is in
kenosha and he spoke to people
gearing up for the president's visit
there mulla good morning to you and very
interested what are people saying
well good morning tony a lot of
different views as you can imagine on
the president's visit here to kenosha
today you know some folks we spoke with
welcome the president and say that he
can help heal and unify this community
while others are concerned that he will
only inflame an already tense situation
and that this will be nothing more
than a photo op we've had several days
of peace here
that's kenosha sheriff david beth he and
other local officials are hoping
residents
keep the peace when the president visits
beth has blamed outside agitators
for most of the violence over the last
week there's been over 200 arrests
since this started over half of those
have come from outside of kenosha
this is not just a sweep your hand over
the whole world and
everything's going to be okay and
everybody's going to love each other
some of the worst damage happened in the
neighborhood surrounding pastor david
montgomery's church
an area full of minority-owned
businesses his church was mostly spared
last week
as many stores on his street went up in
flames president's coming into town
tomorrow
do you think that's good it could be a
position where it
may cause even more uprising
it's not about a photo op it's about
what's what's fruit is gonna manifest
from you coming what's your plan there
was no justification for this there was
there was no justification for this at
all but for others
the president's visit is inspirational
scott carpenter's family owned a
furniture store in town
for more than 30 years it now
sits in a pile of rubble i think it is
going to be helpful that president trump
comes here he can see the destruction
that is caused by
the the violence that is ensued
by the following of what's going on here
and maybe we can
pull some things together
well this is the sort of damage the
president is coming to kenosha to see
uh destruction from the first few nights
the more turbulent nights of those
protests
last week meanwhile during the
president's visit a counter
rally is expected just a few miles from
here at the location where jacob blake
was shot
blake's family is expected to speak
there anthony all right mola thank you
and